okay this is me just clearing the deck
[Music]
all right so this is hopefully the last
San Diego comic-con aside from the
Doctor Who panel you know that I'm gonna
be doing because there were a number of
other things that were talked about
revealed or shown at comic-con that I do
want to say something about but I don't
want to devote whole videos to so this
is basically the miscellaneous pile so
I'm just going down a list of the stuff
that I wrote down that I wanted to talk
about Buffy the Vampire Slayer
apparently getting a reboot and now this
is not the first attempt to reboot this
the thing has been talked about being
rebooted a number of times this is no
worthy for I feel one reason but there's
another thing that people are talking
about that I'll mention I'll get to that
so the reason I feel is noteworthy is
this time they're actually involving
Joss Whedon because the last time there
was talk of rebooting it I believe they
were talking about as a film franchise
they were not going to include Joss
Whedon in any way shape or form they're
basically just gonna bank on the name
this time he is involved I believe he's
gonna be set up as an executive producer
he's probably not gonna be show running
this thing or at least I didn't see that
that was the plan or the intention but
having him in some way involved or at
least him signing off on it to me makes
it more worthwhile he's gonna pique the
interest of a lot of fans a lot more
than just the name does because it's one
of those cases where he will his touch
was that brand in many ways so taking
you know doing it company completely in
his absence doesn't make a whole lot of
sense now the change that I actually
don't think is even that worth talking
about but apparently other people do is
that the intention is to have an a black
actress play Buffy cool fine
because Buffy is a character that I feel
her her background as a Caucasian is not
especially overly engrained in her
character and not really something that
came up a ton so I feel that you can add
that as an element and it should not
upend the character in any severe way
and if you dig into it and to
what it would have meant you know the
way this could be interesting is
especially if they said it in high
school yeah which is what I hope they'll
do because normally when you know
something was originally sent high
school let's reboot it well we'll have
them as adults what we had are as adults
to the show ran for seven years so if
they're rebooting and setting in high
school again which is what they think
they should do
I think updating the timeline to what
high schools are like today and having
the experience of a black student as
opposed to a white one could be an
interesting new thing to add into that
but it doesn't require a massive change
to the overall dynamic or shape or
personality of the character if they
don't want to do that so I'm on board
for that next up there was a new trailer
for fantastic beasts and where to find
them the crimes of Grindelwald holy God
do I hate saying that title but it is
significantly better than the previous
trailer like holy cow it is leagues
better it is way more interesting it is
way more tricky I feel like I got a
better sense of who Newt Scamander is as
a person from that like 15 second clip
of him as a student and finding out that
his greatest fear when he's facing a
boggart was working a desk job I feel
like in that quick flashback I
understood him so much better than I did
after the entirety of the first movie so
that is all up Dickey and there is one
moment that I know other people have
notice and I'm going to acknowledge here
that I was surprised to see and gives me
a flicker of hope now there's also
cynicism attached to that but again I'll
try and keep this short so I have gone
on the record multiple times as being
very upset with the statements from both
JK Rowling and David Yates that
Dumbledore's status as a gay man which
rattling continues to say is the case
would not be in some way confirmed in
this film even though both he and the
object of his affection Grindelwald
played by Johnny Depp are both in it I'm
on the record as not being very upset
when they said no we're not gonna really
touch on and acknowledge that now
there's a scene in this that is
Dumbledore in front of a mirror
and there was a looming figure of
Grindelwald basically over his shoulder
now the shot is not tall enough for us
to see the top of that mirror to know
for certain but if we assume that that
mirror is the mirror of Erised said
which you would know from the first
Harry Potter book and film that means
that it is showing him what he most
desires and so if what he most desires
is Grindelwald that is at the very least
a visual acknowledgement if not a
confirmation of his affections for him
now
I'm I'm not completely abandoning my
cynicism because it's the kind of shot
that could be done so quickly that part
of me wonders did they add that in after
the controversy or is like this gonna be
the full extent of it but they're just
still not going to make it any clearer
than that
and if that's the case I kind of wish
they had said there will be some nods
toward it but we're not being blamed
which wasn't what they said they said
they weren't they were just not gonna do
it which is what leads me to believe I
think this was a later add-on even if it
was it's a good add-on um this does not
I'm not giving them the benefit of the
doubt to say this was always planned and
they were just hiding it from school why
would they hide that all they did was
stir up crap and get in trouble
so yeah I don't buy that one at all but
the trailers much even setting that
issue aside it's nice to see that there
may be some form of acknowledgment and
setting that aside trailer way better
way better than the trailer then the
first trailer that we got for this so
that was good made me happy what else
have I got American Horror Story show I
have not talked about on this channel at
all but I have watched not all of I
think a season 5 whatever one was hotel
that was the last one that I saw I've
been meaning to get around to the others
but I haven't gotten to it but I do like
the show and the new season has a title
announced and it's Apocalypse and more
specifically it is confirmed that is
going to be picking up on threads left
by seasons 1 which was very good in
season 3 which was not very good so that
may gives me a very mixed feeling but
dangling plot thread at the very end of
the first season now called the murder
house season is the biggest thing that
has been waiting to be picked back up on
and dealt with and I do have to wonder
if finally tying off that loose end
means that this might be the last season
of the show maybe maybe not that's pure
speculation on my part on my part I
don't have much more to say about that
but I mean it's always been an
interesting show and I do need to get
back into it to see some of the more
recent seasons even though I've kind of
heard mixed things about them so other
than that let's see oh we got a release
date for iron fist season two in
September I read I thought we were gonna
get daredevil season three before we got
our in fist season two but no so look
fair's fair
Danny is working better as a character
when he was in the defenders and when he
appeared in Luke Cage ie
he's better when he's not carrying the
show that said he's still not great he's
getting better but he's still not great
big acknowledgment Scot buck is not
running this season
Scot buck ran the first season he ran
the inhumans he is i he's one of those
guys who I think he must be able to
deliver on time and under budget very
consistently because the quality of his
work is such that I am stunned that he
is still employed to make television I'm
flabbergasted by that so he's not
involved in this however the guy who is
show running doesn't give me a lot of
faith sky by the name of Rey's Raven
Meixner who started his career in
Hollywood by writing the script for
Elektra the one with Jennifer Garner and
I I don't really want to hold that
against him cuz it was a while ago and I
mean it's how he got started he would
have just been jumping on whatever job
he could get unfortunately the stuff
he's done since then has pretty much all
been in TV and I shows I don't watch so
that's the only thing I've got to judge
him on but he's still better than Scott
whoo I've watched actively ruin shows
including ones I used to love Dexter so
moving on from that Star Wars
the Clone Wars getting basically a nice
little tie off season which is cool now
I've never watched the Clone Wars I've
seen bits I've seen pieces I've seen
clips I never took the time to get into
it and that's not me being dismissive
like great it looks terrible though
looks pretty good but I've just never
had the time and time these days is
something I'm very short of for those of
you who don't realize I have a full-time
job in addition to this so until such
time as this is my living I don't really
have time for shows that I'm that far
behind on or if I ever get to them it's
gonna take it's gonna be a slow slow
slog to get through them but I do think
it's very cool because I did know that
there were plot threads that were
stopped because they ended that so that
they could do rebels instead and they
just left things to not be resolved so I
do like that that's happening you know
what it feel you know I I expect it
feels like for Clone Wars fans is
similar to me because I really like
Farscape and I loved it when it was
airing when it was canceled I was so I
was heartbroken but there was enough of
a push for it that it got basically a
miniseries to tie up its last few things
man I feel that this is this is probably
a similar feeling that that Clone Wars
fans are having so I'm glad you get to
have that and I'm glad and I'm glad
you're gonna get a nice completion and
it feels like you know in the wake of
the men response to solo and the
divisive response to the last Jedi III
it's looking like maybe Lucasfilm is
going you know what let's um maybe we
don't know best on everything what were
some things that the fans really like
that we can kind of throw them the throw
of them a bone on oh they really like
the Clone Wars
you know let's finish that and while it
might be again a cynical move to garner
some goodwill from a fan base it's a
good cynical move it's the right kind of
cynical move because there are people
are like there's some people
really hung up on motivations like
they're doing the right thing for the
wrong reason I might look that's not
perfect but it's the right thing it's
the right thing and if it's a good
result if it's a good result I can live
with the fact that it's cynically
motivated so that's cool and I just got
one last thing I want to say Jamie Lee
Curtis is friggin awesome if you did not
hear this story so there's the new
Halloween movie coming out which is a
sequel to the first and is disregarding
absolutely everything else and Jamie Lee
Curtis is back as Laurie Strode and she
and there was a comic-con panel and she
was at it and there during the question
and answer session there was a fan who
came up you know to the microphone if
you've ever been to a comic-con Q&A
section you know you get in line you get
up to the microphone gasp question they
answer it so there was a guy who came up
to the microphone and he credited the
original Halloween and Jamie Lee Curtis
as character with saving his life
because he was the victim of a home
invasion by a man with a knife and he
was able to survive that and he credited
being able to draw on the strength that
he saw her exhibit in that film as
something that he was able to to tap
into to remember to Center him to help
him get through a situation that he
might otherwise have frozen up during
and could have died and upon being told
this story Jamie Lee Curtis did
something that the people on these
panels never do she got up came out from
behind the table came around and she
hugged this guy she just hugged him and
for a while and that kind of that kind
of comforting everything's okay hug and
it was awesome and if you didn't already
love Jamie Lee Curtis you should and if
this is not enough to get you to love
her look up other stuff about her she's
really kind of awesome so that's it
that's my wrap up for what was left from
San Diego comic-con that is and Doctor
Who related because like I said I got
some more stuff coming out from that I'm
really looking forward to being caught
up so I can leave the spine so these
things from comic-con anything else from
comic-con that I didn't talk about that
you wish I did whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it you know the stuff
that you can do is for me a pager
the big one but you know whatever links
for that and a whole bunch of other
stuff it's all done in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]